ONE REPUBLICAN ARRIVES.
I THINK THOSE ARE THE RULES.
AND WE'LL HEAR THE FIRST BILL
FROM [inaudible]
MISS ATKINS --
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE [inaudible]
YEAH
.
THERE WE GO [inaudible]
GOV WORKOUT.
YOU SPEAK. TO MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER HARPER WELCOME.
WE WILL GET UNDERWAY --
DON'T QUITE HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE ARE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
THE FIRST BILL WE WILL HEAR IS
FROM MISS ATKINS IT'S SB. TEN
EIGHTY SIX WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
AND I I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE COURTESY OF ALLOWING ME
TO GO FIRST --
SP TEN EIGHTY SIX PERMANENTLY
EXTENDS THE WINDOW OF TIME
DURING WHICH FAMILY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER WHOSE
DEATH.
IS ATTRIBUTABLE TO A SERIOUS JOB
CAUSED ILLNESS.
ARE ELIGIBLE TO COLLECT SURVIVOR
DEATH BENEFITS.
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
CONSTANTLY FACE LIFE THREATENING
SCENARIOS AS WE ALL KNOW.
MANY WHICH INVOLVE EXPOSURE TO
DANGEROUS CANCEROUS TOXINS.
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES THE
FAMILIES OF OFFICERS WHO DIED AS
A RESULT OF EXPOSURE. TO THOSE
TOXINS ACCESS TO A MODEST DEATH
BENEFIT.
PART OF TWENTY FIFTEEN HOWEVER
IF AN OFFICER DIED MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED FORTY WEEKS AFTER A
DIAGNOSIS.
THEIR FAMILY BECAME INELIGIBLE
FOR THESE BENEFITS.
IN RECOGNITION OF MEDICAL
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE ARBITRARY
NATURE OF THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
WEEK CAP.
GOVERNOR BROWN IN THE
LEGISLATURE EXTENDED THE
ELIGIBILITY PERIOD FOR THESE
FAMILIES TO FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
WEEKS AND TWENTY FIFTEEN HOWEVER
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THAT TIMELINE
WILL REFER BACK.
A TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY WEEKS ON
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN
WE ARE AWAITING DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION ABOUT THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE EXTENSION.
HAS HAD OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS.
IN THE MEANTIME HOWEVER THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE FOUNDATION HAS
FOUND THAT ONLY TWO FIREFIGHTER
FAMILIES.
HAVE ACCESS THIS ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT WE THEREFORE BELIEVE THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL
ARE MINIMAL WHAT THE BENEFIT TO
THESE FAMILIES IS SIGNIFICANT.
WHETHER A PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
LIFE IS LOST IN AN INSTANT ARE
SLOWLY DUE TO A WORK RELATED
TERMINAL ILLNESS.
BOTH INSTANCES SHOULD BE HONORED
AS THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
IN THE NAME OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
S. B. TEN EIGHTY SIX WILL INSURE
THAT THESE OFFICERS GRIEVING
FAMILIES ARE NOT DEPRIVED OF THE
BENEFITS.
THEY DESERVE DUE TO AN ARBITRARY
AND UNFAIR TIMELINE.
I ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS CHRISTY VELMA
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
WELCOME CHRISTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA FRO OF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS POLICE
TO BE SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE.
OF OUR AUTHOR STATED PERFECTLY I
THINK I'VE JUST.
REMIND YOU THAT THE STATUTE THAT
ORIGINALLY AUTHORIZES EXTENDED
TIMELINE HAD TWO DISTINCTIVE
CHARACTERISTICS FROM THE FROM
THE LAW THAT WAS IN EXISTENCE
BEFORE THAT WITCHES.
THIS EXTENDED TIME WHEN IS ONLY
AVAILABLE. FOR FAMILIES WHO LOST
A LOVED ONE WHO WAS DIAGNOSED
WHILE THEY WERE IN ACTIVE
SERVICE THAT IS NOT A LIMITATION
FOR ALL OF THE INJURED WORKERS.
AND IT ALSO ONLY APPLIES TWO
THREE TYPES OF INJURIES CANCER
TUBERCULOSIS AND BLOODBORNE
PATHOGENS SO IN THIS RESPECT
IT'S VERY NARROW WE THINK THAT.
THE DATA THAT HAS BEEN COLLECTED
HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT THE IMPACT
IS THE MINIMUS BUT THE ES ARE
AUTHOR STATED THE IMPACT ON THE
FAMILY IS TREMENDOUS AND SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IF
MARIA GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL PEACE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS BENEFIT ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
ANY PERSONS HERE WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
IF NOT --
FOUR I INVITE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE LET'S A TAKE ROLE IN
ESTABLISHING WARM.
HERE MAYES HERE [inaudible]
ALLOW [inaudible]
A HERO [inaudible]
CALDERON THEIR CHEN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
YOU'RE.
IT SAYS.
HERE.
CRISIS HERE [inaudible]
HARPER.
PRESENT AT LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
IF APPROPRIATE.
I'M FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
VIEWING AND LISTENING PUBLIC AND
OTHER MEMBERS --
LAST EVENING THE ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE --
AUTHORIZED THE RE REFERRAL TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SO THE
MOTION WOULD BE [inaudible] TO
PASS. TO APPROACH TO SELL MOVE.
MY THERE'S MOTION SECOND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
I'M RECOMMENDING A YES VOTE ON
THIS BILL IT'S A GREAT BILL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT TO US.
AND IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS LET'S DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE [inaudible]
I FAMILY I MAYES.
MAYES I'VE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CABALLERO.
CALDERON BY CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
FRAZIER MY FRAZIER AYE GIPSON --
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER [inaudible]
HARPER I THAT BILL HAS NINE
VOTES. NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU
SO MUCH MAY THINK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN YOU BET THANK YOU.
AND OF MEMBERS WE IF TO ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR LET'S GO
AHEAD AND HANDLE THOSE THOSE.
S. B. TEN FORTY SIX AND S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE THERE'S A
MOTION AND A SECOND [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE DALY I I
MAYES [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
I THE ARROW [inaudible]
CALDERON.
AUTHOR AND I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE IT SAYS
--
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
BY GRAYSON AYE HARPER.
AYE HARPER AYE.
THAT KID HAS. NINE ZERO NINE TWO
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
WE HAVE A THREE BILLS AND TO
AUTHORS.
EXCUSE ME YOUR IT TO AUTHORS
MISTER LARA.
IN MISTER MCGUIRE WHO WE ARE
[inaudible]
AWAITING [inaudible]
THEIR ARRIVAL [inaudible]
AND APPRECIATE THE MOST OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARRIVING NOW.
SORRY WE HAVE TO WAIT.
BY THE WAY I HAVE TO PRESENT A
BILL LIVE TO LEAVE AT ABOUT NINE
TWENTY FIVE WILL BE TURNING IT
OVER TO THE CAPABLE MISTER
MAKES.
IF FOR WELLAND COUNCILS OKAY
[inaudible]
YEAH
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
I'VE GOT SOME OLD JOKES I CAN
TELL JIM [inaudible]
AT THAT [inaudible]
YOU ARE.
YOU MEAN THE NET.
SO WHERE HAVE WE TRIED TO REACH
MISTER LARA.
COOL THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT
[inaudible]
I WILL
.
WELCOME MR LARA.
YOU HAVE A TWO BILLS TO PRESENT
S. B..
THIRTY S. FIRST GO AHEAD PLEASE.
WE ARE ASKING YOU KNOW I THE
QUESTION HOW CAN WE WORK WITH
INSURANCE AND REINSURANCE
COMPANIES TO INCENTIVIZE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES.
THE BILL'S INSPIRED BY A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES THAT I LEARNED
ABOUT.
WHAT WE WERE --
IN BONN GERMANY --
EXAMPLES IN MEXICO AND IN
BARBADOS FOR WE SEE LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES WORKING TOGETHER TO
INVEST IN NATURAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CANCUN ARE
REASSURED COMPANIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS HAVE
PIONEERED INSURANCE POLICY FOR
THE CORAL REEF.
I IN THIS POLICY LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS NEAR CORAL REEF
PAY INTO A COLLECTIVE INSURANCE
PREMIUM THE REEF PROVIDES
PROTECTION AGAINST STORM STORMS
--
AND OTHER CATASTROPHES AS AND IF
DESTRUCTION AND OF IF A
DESTRUCTIVE STORM DAMAGE IS A
CORE REEF THE SURE WILL PAY OUT
THE FUNDS FOR THE RESTORATION.
THIS ALLOWS --
FOR A DIFFERENT TYPE OF FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT'S QUICK THAT
DOESN'T IMPACT THE GENERAL FUND
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OR OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS TYPE OF APPROACH IS THOUGHT
TO BE THE FIRST IN THE WORLD TO
TIE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
THE ECOSYSTEM SERVICE OF STORM
PROTECTION TO MONETARY COST AND
REWARDS.
THIS IS LIKELY THE FIRST TIME
AND SURE HAS ACTUALLY ALSO
COVERED A NATURAL STRUCTURE IN
BARBADOS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
USING MARKET MECHANISMS. TO
INVEST IN THEIR MANGROVE SWAMPS
AND CORAL REEFS.
THESE INVESTMENTS IMPROVE STAR
PROTECTION AND MITIGATE AGAINST
FUTURE DAMAGE.
IT IS SAID THAT AFTER EVERY
MAJOR STORM IT IMPACTS OF THE
BARBADOS GDP BY 4% SO THIS IS OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE FOR THEM.
BUT AND WHAT IS ANALOGOUS TO US
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN LOOK
AT NOT ONLY SEA LEVEL RISE
BECOME A COVER WITH THE
RESTORATION OF OUR WETLANDS.
AND OF COURSE FOREST'S
MANAGEMENT FOR A AND WE CAN USE
INSURANCE INCENTIVES TO REWARD
GOOD BEHAVIOR AND REDUCE
EXPOSURE OF THE STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OR BUSINESS. TO
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED LOSSES
THIS ACTUALLY ALSO GIVE THEM
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR REINSURANCE
COMPANIES AND SHOWS COMPANIES TO
ACTUALLY BE PART AND WELCOME
INTO THE ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT.
AS OPPOSED TO CAN SIMPLY JUST
YOU KNOW ATTACKING THAT THE
INDUSTRY I THINK THIS THE GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER AND CREATE SOME
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
THAT ALLOW OF THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY TO BE PART OF OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
MR LAURA THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND MY
RECOMMENDATION IS OF OF A
SUPPORT --
ON THIS BILL --
YOU HAVE OTHER FOLKS WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN.
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
IT'S LIKE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU GENERAL ARE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LOUIS BLUMBERG.
AND THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CHANGE PROGRAM FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
WE ARE PLEASED TO BE THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND HERE TO BE HERE
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS A VERY SIMPLE STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL THAT WOULD.
CREATE A PROCESS THAT WILL
GENERATE INFORMATION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO IN SUPPORT AND
EXPAND THE STATE'S GOAL OF
PREPARING FOR CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE STUDY GROUP TO BE CREATED BY
THE BILL WOULD EVALUATE
POTENTIAL FOR SURE INSURANCE TO
UNDERWRITE NATURAL RESOURCE
PROTECTION. TO INCREASE
RESILIENCE AND REDUCE RISK TO
PEOPLE AND BIT BUSINESSES AND
PRIVATE PROPERTY --
A KEY A CONCEPT OF THIS OF THIS
OF THE BILL AND AND THE HOPE
EFFORT THAT WE'RE DOING IS THAT
NATURE REDUCES THE RISK.
IF YOU LOOK AT FIVE RISKS THAT
CALIFORNIA FACES RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE ALL A CURRENT RICH THAT
ARE EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE ONE ITS WILDFIRE.
DROUGHT.
FLOODING SHE LEVEL RISE AND
IRVINE HIGH HEAT NATURE CAN BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION SHED SET
FOR ALL FIVE OF THOSE.
THOSE RISKS AND FOR THIS BILL
WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW WE
COULD USE THE INSURANCE AGENCY
AND INDUSTRY TO CREATE A NEW
MARKET MECHANISM. TO REDUCE WHAT
THESE THESE RISK THAT WE ALL
FACE AND A GREAT EXAMPLE IS THE
COASTAL WETLANDS THAT CENTER
LARA DID AN EXCELLENT ELOQUENT
JOB OF DESCRIBING.
OUR SCIENCE SHOWS THAT A CORAL
REEF A IN PLACE CAN REDUCE THE
WAVE ENERGY BY 97%.
SO THIS THAT NATURE IS A
POWERFUL TOOL IN ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE --
THIS BILL IS ALSO WELL ALIGNED
WITH THE PRIORITIES OF THE
LEGISLATURE AROUND CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO OTHER OTHER
BILLS.
ARE A S. B. --
THREE SEVENTY NINE SP TWO FORTY
SIX I ENJOYED IT AT AND ADDS TO
THE STATE'S POLICY PLATFORM FOR
DEALING WITH CLIMATE CHANGE WE'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR LARA FOR
HIS INITIATIVE IN HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE.
ARE AND RESPECTFULLY ARCHER AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THERE.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND
HANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR COMMENTS
SIR.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS CATHERINE
PETTIBONE AMERICAN INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION YEAH PLEASE TO
SUPPORT WITH THE THE BILL'S
AMENDMENTS --
WE'VE TALKED WITH THE AUTHOR
INITIALLY ARE COMPANIES WE HAVE
INTERNATIONAL NATIONAL.
INSURERS AND REINSURERS AND THEY
ARE THE ONES DOING A LOT OF THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS ACTIVITY DOING
REALLY CREATIVE SOLUTIONS --
I KNOW THEY'RE EXCITED TO YOU
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT IS QUITE
STRICT.
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I HOPE
IS EXAMINED YOU KNOW AS WE GO
FORWARD BECAUSE INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS ARE CREATIVE.
AND NEW AND SO THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION WE ALSO --
CEMENT THAT YOU TO OUR FOLKS
SURGED IN THAT KIND OF THE RISK
TRANSFER A MECHANISM IT ISN'T
JUST INSURANCE POLICIES THERE'S
A VARIETY THERE'S GOING TO BE P.
THREE PROJECTS.
AND ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT I
THINK ARE GOING TO BE EXCITING
TO EXAMINE TO SEE WHAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO UNDER THAT SIR
WORKING GROUP AND WILL BE
PLEASED TO PARTICIPATE SO THANK
YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER PERSONS HERE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY VERY
INTERESTING CREATIVE APPROACH
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
RESULTS OF THE STUDY COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF MOURNING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JONATHAN PART FOR A I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
BASED ORGANIZATION CLIMATE
RESOLVED.
AND WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO
SENATOR LARA FAIR SB THIRTY AND
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND I SERVED AS A COMMISSIONER
AT THE LA DEPARTMENT OF WATER
AND POWER FOR FIVE YEARS AND LET
ME TELL YOU WE TOOK INSURANCE
VERY SERIOUSLY.
ITS WAY IN WHICH THAT THE MARKET
CAN DEAL WITHOUT CATASTROPHES
AND NOW AS A DIRECTOR OF A
CLIMATE CHANGE ORGANIZATION --
WE'RE VERY WELL AWARE OF WHAT
CLIMATE CHANGE PORTENTS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
CAN BE A MAJOR PLAYER.
AND ALLOWING THE MARKETPLACE TO
RESPOND TO THIS CRISIS.
ALSO WE STAND FIRM SUPPORT WE
ALSO VERY INTERESTED ESPECIALLY
IN URBAN FEET ARE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE BILL FOCUSES IN ON ON
NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS.
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS HOWEVER.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE LIVING
IN CITIES THAT --
ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE DUE TO
NATURAL HEAT AND THE WARMING FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE WE ALSO WANT TO
PROTECT THEM AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE BILL COULD EXPAND. TO
INCLUDE THEM AS WELL AGAIN SIR
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
ANYONE HERE WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL.
IF NOT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND MISTER LORE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN YOU KNOW ARE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY THE EXPERTS AND RISKS
--
Y. NOT UTILIZE THAT EXPERTISE TO
HELP WITH COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND A LAKE WOULD HAVE BEFORE.
MOTHER NATURE IS ALREADY
PROVIDED THESE NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURES TO PROTECT US
AGAINST SEA LEVEL RISE AND A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS WHY DON'T
WE ARE USES INNOVATIVE APPROACH
HAS BEEN USED AROUND THE WORLD.
TO PROTECT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE AND INVOLVE AN INDUSTRY
IN A WAY THAT HASN'T BEEN
INVOLVED BEFORE IN THIS EFFORTS
UP BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL.
BEAUTIFUL ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IF NOT THE ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CABALLERO.
ALTHOUGH.
I CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER I COOPER AYE FRAZIER AYE
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE.
THE BILL HAS ELEVEN ZERO VOTE.
THAT BILL PASSED.
ELEVEN TWO ZERO THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES WHOSE WHO HELPED
[inaudible]
TITUS SO THAT BILL PASSED ELEVEN
ZERO MISTER LARA I HAVE TO GO TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEES WOMAN TO TURN
THIS OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR
MISTER MAYES HOURS.
A SIMILAR YOU'VE GOT --
SP TWENTY FOUR YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I LIKE TO BEGIN BY.
A COMMITTEE TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGE THREE
OF THE ANALYSIS A IN JUDICIARY
DUE TO THE TIMING OF ITS BILL
DOUBLE REFERRAL.
I THINK AGAIN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE WORK THE CAR.
ARE THE RESULT OF ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS AND I WANTED THAT I
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
INVOLVEMENT IN THE PROCESS.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL PROHIBIT
INSURERS FROM CANCELLING OR NOT
RENEWING THE HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE POLICY FOR ONE YEAR
AFTER THE DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY FOR A PROPERTY LOCATED
WITHIN THE FIRE PERIMETER.
AS DETERMINED BY CAL FIRE OR
WITHIN THE ZIP CODE ADJACENT TO
THE FIRE PERIMETER.
AFTER MASS DESTRUCTION FROM
WILDFIRE OR FLOODS IT STANDS TO
REASON THAT INSURERS ARE LIKELY
TO RE EXAMINE THEIR EXPOSURE TO
RISK IN THOSE IMPACTED AREAS.
BY EXTENDING THE FRONT THE ISSUE
TO ONE YEAR TO WHEN YOU'RE IN
YOUR REQUIREMENT.
UP TO HOMES IN THE MEDIA IS
RUNNING DISASTER AREAS WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT HOMEOWNERS WHO
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE BEEN DAMAGED
IN THE DISASTER DON'T HAVE TO
STRUGGLE WITH THE SITE AND NON
RENEWAL.
OR CANCELLATION IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THE EVENT THE ONE YEAR
RENEWAL REQUIREMENT PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL CAN ACT AS A BUFFER TO
EXTEND COVERAGE AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL AND MUCH NEEDED TIME
FOR HOMEOWNERS. TO CONSIDER
LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVES AS BE A
TWENTY FOUR WILL ALSO OPTIMIZE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. TO
CONDUCT THE DATA CALL UNINSURED
LOSSES RELATED TO FIRE AND
WILDFIRES I HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE INSURERS IN THE
DEPARTMENT.
TO REFINE THE LANGUAGE --
OF THE BIANNUAL DATA CALL WHICH
WILL INCLUDE REQUIREMENTS FOR
INFORMATION ON PREMIUMS THAT USE
OF VIRUS CORES --
AND FIRE OR WILDFIRE INCURRED
LOSSES AMONG OTHER FACTORS THIS
WILL BE DONE ON A PER POLICY
BASIS JOE FORMATS ABOUT THE
GROWING WELFARE RISK.
AND ANY BEARING THAT HAS ON THE
AVAILABILITY OR AFFORDABILITY OF
SOMEBODY'S INSURANCE.
OF INFORM.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND MARCH
HIDE IT HIGHLIGHTED THE IMMENSE
NEED FOR DATA ON THIS TOPIC THIS
PROPOSED DATA BECAUSE SOLUTION
TO THAT PROBLEM AS TECH WE ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT
THAT'S ACKERMAN MR TURN MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
PLAZA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ADVICE I CAN
OFFER SUPPORT ON GAP OF C. SAKON
RC RC WHO ARE NOT HERE TODAY.
UNFORTUNATELY BUT PLACER COUNTY
BROUGHT THIS MEASURE TO THE
SENATOR BECAUSE THEY WERE HIT BY
THE SUPERVISORS THERE HAVE BEEN
HEARING. FOR ACTUALLY COUPLE OF
YEARS ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY IN
OBTAINING INSURANCE THAT IS
AFFORDABLE OR THE NON RENEWALS
THAT HAVE BEEN OCCURRING OR A
PREMIUMS GOING.
I REALLY REALLY HIGH DESPITE
HOMEOWNERS.
A MITIGATING THEIR PROPERTY IN
WAYS FOR EVEN CAL FIRE WAS USING
HOMEOWNERS PROPERTY THE STAGE
FOR FIRE FIGHTS AND THOSE
HOMEOWNERS ARE HAVING TROUBLE.
ACCESSING INSURANCE SO I THEY
CAME IN AND SPOKE WITH THE
SENATOR AND HE WAS A GRACIOUS
ENOUGH TO MOVE.
AYE TO INTRODUCE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I OBVIOUSLY NOW WITH
THAT WITH WHAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR AT THE DATA ON HOW.
ATTAINABLE INSURANCE IS IS
CRITICAL FOR FOLKS THAT ARE
LIVING IN THE WILD MAN URBAN
INTERFACE THE DATA CALL PEACE
WILL HOPEFULLY INFORM.
I'VE BOTH COUNTY SURPRISES THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE HOW THE
MARKET IS FUNCTIONING IN THOSE
AREAS AND HOW OBTAINABLE
INSURANCE AS IN THE REGULATED
MARKET SOMEONE HOMEOWNERS MOVE.
TO IRAN SURPLUS LINES WHICH ARE
LIKE.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY FALL
INTO ANY KIND OF DATA THAT UP
BILL THE STATE'S COLLECTING SO
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THOSE
HOMEOWNERS.
WHO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO OBTAIN INSURANCE
AND ARE MAINTAINING THEIR
PROPERTY IN THE EVENT OF FIRE?
AYE BREAKS OUT SO THAT THEY HAVE
A DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS THE COUNTY ISN'T STRONG
SUPPORT WE HAVE CREE ABOUT TODAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GOVERNMENT'S ARREST HER
MEMBERS ROBERT RELATIVE TO
COMMISSIONER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE A WE
SUPPORT THE BILL --
THAT BRIEFLY ON THE DATA COPIES
WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT
COLLECTION OF THIS DATA WILL
WIND UP HELPING THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THE NO
INDIVIDUAL INSURER AND MANY
CASES HAS ENOUGH EXPERIMENTAL
DATA.
PARTICULARLY IN THE WE OR THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE AREA OF
THAT MS LINK SPOKE OF OUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO SOMETIMES MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR RISK.
AND THAT THAT RISK PROFILE THAT
THE STATE WILL HELP THAT IT'S
SIMILAR IN SOME RESPECTS TO
SOMETHING THAT WE ALREADY DO IN
THE AUTO AREA THAT WE HAVE FOUND
TO BE HELPFUL AS WELL.
I'M SWITCHING GEARS BRIEFLY ARE
ON TO THE OTHER PART ON THE
RENEWALS --
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT PROCESS AND
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUING TO DO SO
WHICH IS NOT THAT IN THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON FIVE BE.
A WE DO NEED TO TALK A BIT MORE
ABOUT THIS FINANCIAL SOLVENCY
STANDARDS OF BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS IN
A CONSTRUCTIVE MANNER OR DRIVE
OUT TODAY AND THINK THE SENATOR
FOR HIS EFFORTS IN THIS AREA.
AND ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I JOINED BY JOE LARGER THE CHIEF
DEPUTY FOR THE DEPARTMENT CASE
ANYBODY WANTS TO GET IN THE
WEEDS NOT THAT WE'RESUGGESTING
THAT YOU DO THIS MORNING.
OKAY ANY OTHER OF MEDICINAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOING ONCE GOING TWICE.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
I'M FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING CARA CROSS FOR THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST WANTED THAT
THANK SENATOR LARA IS STOPPING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
I'M WE ARE REMAINING OPPOSED LOS
AMENDED HOWEVER WE ARE VERY
ENCOURAGED BY THE PROGRESS OF
THIS BILL IN THE WORK WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS --
AND HAPPY TO HEAR THAT THAT ARE
LARA'S COMMITTEE THE TAKE THAT
MADMAN SLIPPING RECOMMENDED BY
THE COMMITTEE.
THE ONLY THING IT WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SOME CLARIFICATIONS ON THE
FACT THE SUPPLIES.
TO ON SOY RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
NOT COMMERCIAL THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE MONTHLY SHALL BE
HAVE A PC AYE.
OUT ONE THING CENTER LARA STAFF
AS WELL AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WORK WITH US WERE VERY CLOSE AYE
WE SEE WE HAVE AN OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED THAT.
WERE ALMOST THERE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MCKEE
REPRESENTED THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING ON THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND WE BELIEVE WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
VERY SOON THANK YOU.
CATERPILLAR BUT AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION OF ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
RIGHT A FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THEN NO MISTER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU CHAIR I'D JUST. FOR
CLARIFICATION ON CLARIFICATION
AS IS YEAH IS IT RESIDENTIAL AND
NOT COMMERCIAL.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ON THURSDAY.
OF WE CONTINUE TO MEET WITH THE
INSURANCE FOLKS WE HAVEN'T MADE
THAT DECISION YET BUT WARM WHAT
HEADING TOWARDS.
OF RESOLVING THE FISHER.
THAT AND WHEN WE'RE FOCUSING ON
RESIDENTIAL THE FOCUS CORRECT.
AND ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT SO WHAT TO MAKE SURE
WHAT MOVING BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEM BY SOME
AMENDMENTS AND SO IS THAT A
MOTION WITH THE AMENDMENTS ARE
WE WAS HE'LL WORKING A CUP THE
AMENDMENTS WERE GONNA TAKE.
IF I CAN ACTUALLY MAY HAVE THAT
THE CONSULTANT JUST.
THERE'S A MARK UP BEFORE THE
MEMBERS.
AS A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS AND
IT.
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
BE TAKEN IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BECAUSE TO DO IN HERE WOULD MESS
UP THE PROCESS PROCEDURE
[inaudible]
BUT TO BE CLEAR.
STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH SIDES HAVE
RESERVED THE RIGHT BEFORE.
OFFICIALLY AMENDED IN JUDEA. TO
TINKER A LITTLE BIT ON THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED --
IN THAT MARKUPS SO.
THAT MARK UP ISN'T --
EVERY I DOTTED EVERY KARMA AS IS
IT STILL GOING TO BE
[inaudible]
SOME NOMINAL.
TINKERING TO BE DONE BY NEXT
WEEK.
IF THAT THATDO THAT BUT I THINK
SO I THINK SO THAT IT --
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT WITH YOUR
MOTION.
MR JEWELL CASE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION WHOSE THE SECOND ON THE
SECOND BY --
CALDERON AND IF THERE IS NOTHING
FURTHER --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
DALY.
MAY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
THINK ABOUT [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
CALDERON BY CALDERON AYE CHEN
[inaudible]
CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON AYE
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER.
NOT VOTE [inaudible]
AT SIX SO DON'T.
HAVE TO BE ON CALL THANK YOU SIR
MEMBERS YEAH.
IF WE HAVE ONE FINAL BILL WITH
THE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
WE DON'T SEE HIM YET SO I GUESS
--
UNLESS SOMEBODY'S GOT SOME
JOKES.
YEAH I GUESS WE CAN'T.
WE DO THAT.
JUST OUR TREES ARE FROM THE TOP
YOU GOTTA.
SURE SURE JUST GOTTA BOTTOM
THIRD ITEM NUMBER.
ONE S. B. [inaudible]
THIRTY CABALLERO [inaudible]
COOLEY.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
CABALLERO.
CHIU AYE CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE.
THAT HAS ELEVEN VOTES.
I LIMITS AND THEN BY NUMBER.
FOUR FINANCE LF.
TEN EIGHTY SIX WE'LL BE
CABALLERO [inaudible]
YOU ARE CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER BY COOPER I THAT HAS
ELEVEN VOTES [inaudible]
AND I THINK AND THE SENATORS
HERE.
SO COME ON COME UP THAT ITEM
NUMBER SIX S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY ONE WELL GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OVER WAS DOING
WELL I THE CHAIRMAN IT ASKED FOR
ABOUT A FIFTEEN MINUTE
PRESENTATION SO I'M AWARE AT
THAT CREEK WELL THE CHAIRMAN IS
LEFT SO THE VICE CHAIR.
AND HOW HARD [inaudible]
DO.
I JUST SEVEN THAT THE DONALD
EVER I'D HATE TO THEIR EGO.
THE HAIL LIKE THIS.
HE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'D.
I SP FIFTY ONE OUT THIS MAKE IT
TWENTY SECONDS IT REPEALS THE
CTB PROGRAM SUNSET DATE AND
PROHIBITION PARTICIPANTS
RECEIVING DISCLOSURE INCOME FROM
OTHER SOURCES DISHONESTY
THINKING THIS CLARK.
A SHE'S A LEGISLATIVE SYSTEM
WITH EDT AND THEIR SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
RESPECT LATHROP.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
IF YOU WANNA CHART PROVIDE SOME
SUPPORT BANQUET REALLY QUICKLY I
AM THE MAIN CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME'S REST OF CLARK I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE EDT IN SUPPORT.
AT THE MENTION THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
CTB PROGRAM MAKING A PERMANENT
PROVISION PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR IT'S A CRITICAL PROGRAM
THAT SUPPORTS.
ELIGIBLE YOU AYE CLAIMANTS IN
THE COMING MARKET.
BY ALLOWING THEM TO YOU AYE
BENEFITS WHILE ATTENDING STATE
APPROVED TRAINING A RETRAINING
PROGRAM THE BUILDINGS ARE THE
STATE REMAINS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
FEDERAL KARMIC COULD RESULT IN
LOSS IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAX CREDITS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYERS AND YOU AS
ADMINISTRATIVE GRANT FUNDING SO
THE EDT VERY MUCH APPRECIATES.
THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR OFFERING
THIS BILL AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HERE.
TO GREAT ANY UP FOR THE ONES
THAT SUPPORT.
WILL.
WE GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND ARE
THERE.
ANY -- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
GOING ONCE.
GOING TWICE --
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION THE
MOTION WAS.
BY.
GIPSON SECOND AYE FRAZIER --
SO WITH THAT THE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
DALY.
MAY I MAYES AYE BIGELOW
[inaudible]
CABALLERO.
CALDERON LIKE CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
I GRAYSON [inaudible]
HARPER.
SIGNED UP THAT S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY ONE AM IST FAILURE DALY
AYE YOUR I WAS JUST OVER IN YOUR
COMMITTEE A THEIR REGALIA PEN
PEN DOWN THERE NOW I APOLOGIZE
ALBEIT IN ALL GO BACK OFF ALL
YOU ARE IS SINCE COULD.
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
YOU'RE THINKING OF THE
CONVENTION.
DID WE FINISH SHARE THE OTHER
LARA BILLS.
WELL DONE --
YOU PLAIN OLD.
CALL AND I'M GOING TO HAVE PAUL
COVER YOU ARE.
WHERE DO IN --
ADD ONS NOW AND WE'RE ALSO
GIVING COOLEY AND MISS CABALLERO
A CHANCE TO ADD ON LET'S GO
THROUGH THE ADD ONS.
YOU'RE ON THAT I GOT TO CHECK.
ON THE ONE HAND YOU ARE ONE ONE
WHEN HE OKAY HAD DATA AROUND FOR
HE DID AROUND HE DID AROUND
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HE GOT ON THE LINE WITH US.
HE'LL COME BACK.
WE'RE DOING OUT ON RIGHT NOW.
ON THAT MCGUIRE BILL. TWELVE A
TWELVE FIFTY ONE I S. B.
[inaudible]
THIRTY ABBY ARROW COOLEY I
COOLEY AYE [inaudible] TWELVE
VOTES -- S.
B. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR DALY.
AYE DALY AYE [inaudible]
THE ARROW.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE. EIGHT
ZERO AFFECT YEAH HE DID --
CONSENT CALENDAR PUPPY AERO.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE THAT HAD.
BOTH [inaudible]
ON S. B. TEN EIGHTY SIX
CABALLERO COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES.
S. B. TWELVE FIFTY ONE
CABALLERO.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE.
YEAH.
THAT HAS TEN VOTE.
HERE I AM WANTING WE'RE DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT HAS A WAITING AROUND JUST FOR
COFFEE SHOPS.
I YEAH NO PROBLEM.
THEY FLEW UP.
MY DISTRICT OFFICE AUBURN
SUPPORT.
YOU LEARNING A GOOD GUY
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
MUSIC.
PERFECT BLOCKS IT ANYWAY
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT WELL [inaudible]
JUST ADJOURNMENT [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
IT DIDN'T.
THIS MADE IN THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED